هذه القبضه التي تشد على يد الرئيس المصري
هي ذاتها التي كانت تلوح بالاصابع الاربعه
اشاره جماعه الاخوان المسلمين المحظوره
مياه كثيره جرت في النهر منذ ذلك الحين او
بالاحرف البحر وتحديدا شرق المتوسط حيث
ثروات الغاز ومطاميع تركيا
طلبوا انقر الوحيد من مصر وتغيير اسلوبها
تجاه وضع تركيا في البحر المتوسط طلب
بسيطا لكنه يوضح مدى تركيا من الحصول على
موطن قدم في عمليه استكشاف الغاز في
المتوسط بسبب تحالفات التي تقيمها مصر
خاصه مع كل من اليونان وقبرص
وتحقيقه هذا المسعى استخدم اردوغان طرقا
عده للضغط سواء بالتلويح بورقه الاخوان او
بتعزيز وجود بلاده العسكري في ليبيا على
بعد كيلو مترات قليله من حدود مصر الغربيه
اما القاهره فلديها سلسله من المطالب
تتوقع ان تستجيب تركيا لها اذا كانت انقر
راغبه بالفعل في تطبيع العلاقات
تم التوافق على ان تكون المصافحه بين
الرئيسين بدايه لتطوير العلاقات الثنائيه
بين الجانبين
قائمه المطالب المصريه من تركيا تتعدد
لتشمل كبحه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ومنعها
من القيام بالتحريض الاعلامي ضد الدوله
المصريه
وتسليم عدد من الاخوان المطلوبين في قضايا
امنيه وسحب المرتزقه من ليبيا وانسحاب
القوات التركيه من هناك
محاولات التقارب بين مصر وتركيا ليست
الاولى بل سبقتها محاولات اخرى على
مستويات اقل وكانت كلها تبوء بالفشل هذه
هي المره الاولى التي يحدث فيها لقاء على
اعلى المستويات بين البلدين وهو ما يفتح
باب الامل لتحقيق اختراقه حقيقيه
تجاهها تطبيع العلاقات